The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
And now I just want
to revisit-- when we
started the unit we listed
a bunch of things that
affected the rates of reaction,
and we see where we are.
We've talked about mechanism.
We've talked about the
nature of the material,
The Arrhenius constant depends
on the nature of the material,
the activation energy
barrier depends
on the nature of the
reactants of the material.
Concentrations and
pressure-- partial pressures,
temperatures.
The only thing we haven't
talked about are catalysts.
So that's what we're
going to focus on today.
We're going to learn
about catalysts and how
they affect kinetics.
So a catalyst, this
is something that's
used by non-scientists,
a lot of laymen talk
about catalyzing something.
There's many companies
with a name catalyst in it.
So a catalyst is
a substance-- this
is its technical definition--
that will speed up a reaction,
but it is not, itself,
consumed by the reaction.
It doesn't undergo
any permanent change.
So it can be thought of a sort
of a helping hand, a lift up.
It makes the reaction go faster.
But it does not appear in the
overall balanced equation,
because it's not
being transformed,
it's not being converted
to something else.
It's just speeding
up the reaction.
OK so now let's go back to our
reaction coordinate diagrams
and think about what
a catalyst is doing.
So back again, potential energy
vs. the reaction coordinate.
We have the potential energy
of our reactants up here,
potential energy of our products
here, delta E, the difference
between them.
But again, before the
reactants can go onto products,
they must overcome an
activation energy barrier.
So EA for the forward direction.
And if they're going from
products to reactants,
they don't have to
just do that, they
have to go way up here first.
And this is the
activation energy barrier
without a catalyst, the
transition state, the activated
complex.
That's the height to
which the molecules
need to get in potential energy
to be able to react and go on.
So we can draw now our curve.
So from reactants we go
up, overcome that barrier,
reach this state, and
then can go onto products.
So they come together,
and you end up
at a lower potential
energy in this case.
But before you get
there, you have
to overcome this
activation energy barrier.
OK.
So this is the diagram
we've seen before.
What is the catalyst doing?
So what the catalyst does is
it decreases this barrier.
So now we have a dashed line
for the barrier with a catalyst,
and we can draw a
new curve over here
so you don't have
to get as high,
you don't have as large
a barrier anymore.
And we can put in
the new barriers.
So in dashed lines now we have
the activation energy barrier
for the forward direction, and
for the reverse direction.
Both of them are less.
This line is below.
The catalyst has lowered the
activation energy barrier.
They typically act by
reducing the barrier,
both for the forward direction
and the reverse direction.
So we can also say-- and people
do-- that catalysts stabilize
or lower the energy of
this transition state,
also known as the
activated complex.
So they bring this down,
they lower the energy needed.
It's easier to get over the
hump when you have a catalyst
and therefore it
speeds up the reaction.
So catalysts have no effect
on the thermodynamics
of the system.
They're affecting the
kinetics of the system,
and this is because free
energy, our friend delta G,
is a state function.
It's independent of path.
OK with these things
in mind, tell me
with a clicker question what
happens to the equilibrium
constant if you have
a catalyst present?
All right.
10 more seconds.
And that is true.
It is not changed.
So the equilibrium
constant is not
changed by the
presence of a catalyst
because this is a
thermodynamic property.
So delta G is not changed,
and the equilibrium constant
is not changed.
So it doesn't depend on path,
and this is a path difference.
The catalyst changes
the path, but it
doesn't change the beginning
state or the end state.
And so just to help
you remember this,
I'll give you a little
trick to remember this.
So again, catalysts
effect the kinetics,
not the thermodynamics.
And one way to remember this
is that the Chinese symbol
for catalysts and marriage
broker are the same.
So a marriage broker
increases the rate
at which a couple comes
together, usually introduces
the two people to each other.
Of course online services
can do this as well,
but none of these things
can make a couple stable
if the couple is not stable.
So online dating services,
marriage brokers,
increase the kinetics, increase
the rate at which people meet,
increase the
encounter, but do not
change the thermodynamics
of the relationship.
A couple is stable or
unstable regardless
of the marriage broker,
regardless of the catalyst.
So affects kinetics,
not thermodynamics.
All right, so there are two
major types of catalysts,
homogeneous
catalysts-- and that is
just when the catalyst
and the reactants
are in the same phase.
An example that has actually
been in the news a bit
this fall is the
ozone layer, depletion
of the ozone by
chlorofluorocarbons,
all in the gas phase.
So this would be the
catalyst for the depletion
is in the same phase as
the thing it's depleting.
And here's a little
picture of the increase
in the ozone hole over time.
But there was some
good news this fall
that it seemed like
the rate of increase
was not as dramatic, that
it was staying a little bit
more level, which is
exciting to know that if we
stop bad behavior,
that we can and we
can have a positive effect.
So we shouldn't just say, oh,
we polluted so much already,
what's a little more?
We've already done
all the damage.
There's no point.
No, no there is a point.
If we stop doing damage,
good thing-- better things
will happen.
So that was some
good news that people
were hearing about this fall.
OK along the pollution lines
of destroying our planet,
there's also heterogeneous
catalyst, so a different phase.
And a common example of this
is the catalytic converter
in a car.
And so catalytic converters
use of metals, solid phase
to help catalyze
reactions of gases,
so solid gas, different phase.
And they try to
convert these gases
to last less toxic pollutants.
And so I'll just give
you a little example
of how this could work.
I'm not a catalytic
converter, but just
in general with this little
movie-- so we have this metal
surface here.
And the metal surface
will absorb H2 gas
and help to dissociate H2.
So here's a hydrogen,
here's a hydrogen absorbed
onto this metal surface.
And then you can flow something
over the metal surface,
and that will be reduced
by the hydrogens.
So let me get this to go.
So here we see,
now the hydrogens
are popping off and going
to reduce ethene over here.
So this is an example of a
heterogeneous catalyst, where
we have metal in a
solid phase that's
catalyzing a reaction
that involves materials
in a different phase.
OK so two types.
But there is also my
very, very favorite type,
which is enzymes.
So we're going to
talk just briefly
about enzyme catalysis,
which will give you a leg
up when you go on to
courses that have something
to do with biochemistry.
And these days biochemistry is
sort of everywhere on campus.
You might think I
can escape biology
to go into chemical engineering.
No, no you can't.
There are a lot of
chemical engineers
that are working
only with enzymes.
So a little bit about
enzymes as catalysts.
So enzymes, large
protein molecules,
20,000 grams per mole or more.
That's a tiny protein.
And they're made
up of amino acids,
and you've seen a lot of
amino acids in this class.
We've been using those
to think about PKA's.
And so here we have an
amino acid with a sidechain,
it's abbreviated R.
There's 20 different R's,
20 different amino acids.
And amino acids come together
forming peptide bonds,
where we have a connection
between this carbonyl
and the nitrogen of
the next amino acid.
So amino acid one amino acid
two and here's the peptide bond.
These then form long
chains, and will fold up
into a compact structure.
So here is an example of
a structure of an enzyme.
And I'll just tell you a
little bit about this enzyme.
So here there are four
polypeptide chains, so one
in green, one in red, one
in yellow, and one in blue.
And they form this
compact structure.
And this picture
shows these ribbons.
Here is alpha helices,
there's squiggly, the arrows,
or beta strands.
And so they draw ribbons through
the alpha carbon position,
so you don't see
all the atoms here
you just kind of see how the
chains wrap around each other
to form this overall
protein structure.
So this particular enzyme
catalyzes the last step
in the biosynthesis of
an antibiotic fosfomycin.
So it converts this reactant
or substrate molecule
into the fosfomycin antibiotic.
Fosfomycin is used in
combination therapy
to treat MRSA infections.
So I have always
tried to give you
examples of important
areas of science
that smart people should go
into and solve these problems,
and I'll just mention antibiotic
resistance with this figure.
This was published in
the journal Nature.
They called it a perfect
storm, because here we
see the increase in
antibiotic resistant strains.
This is MRSA here.
Up to 60% over here.
And these are--
this data is old.
And then that go up, and
here in blue going down
are the new antibiotics that
have been approved for use.
So we have much more
resistance and many fewer
antibiotics being approved.
And so this what has been
called the perfect storm,
and this situation
the y data here 2010.
It's not any better.
In fact, it's worse now, so one
important area is to come up
with new antibiotics.
All right so many of the targets
of antibiotics are enzymes.
Many of the ways to make
antibiotics is using enzymes,
and so enzyme catalysis is
very important for medicine,
and also for engineering
and biofuels.
And people are using enzymes
for pretty much everything
these days.
All right.
So a couple of
terminology-- reactants.
We've been talking
about reactants.
If it's an enzyme, it's
called a substrate.
These terms can really
be used interchangeably.
The substrate will
bind to what's
known as the active
site on an enzyme,
and so as someone who determines
three dimensional structures
of enzyme, it pains me to draw
a picture of an enzyme structure
like this, but I did it anyway.
So here's my enzyme.
That's its active site.
Here is the substrate
molecule, which
is about the same
size as the enzyme--
usually that's not the
case, but anyway-- binding.
And so then when you have enzyme
plus substrate bind together,
we have our ES complex,
ES for enzyme substrate.
And then the enzyme will undo
catalysis, forming product.
And product will be
released, and we'll
have free enzyme again.
So this is a very
simple mechanism
or steps of enzyme
catalysis, but that's OK.
It sometimes can be written
in a very simple way.
And so now, using
what you have already
learned how to do in
our reaction mechanism,
we can derive rate laws and
rate expressions for enzymes.
So you know biochemistry
is really not
much different than anything
else we've been doing.
All the things you've
been learning in chemistry
apply to biochemistry.
Biochemistry or life
is really just a series
of chemical reactions
that obey all
of the same laws and
principles as everything else.
So here we're going to write
an expression for the enzyme
coming together
with its substrate,
forming an intermediate
enzyme substrate complex,
and going on to form
free enzyme and product.
In step one, enzyme and
substrate will come together.
And in the forward
direction, we have
k1 to form the enzyme
complex, and it's also
a reversible step.
In step two, the complex goes
on to form enzyme and product.
So we can now write
these laws, or I
should say you can figure out
how to write these expressions.
These are, again, elementary
steps, elementary reactions.
10 more seconds.
OK let's just take
a look at that.
So over here, again the rate
of the forward direction,
we have the forward rate
constant K1 times enzyme times
substrate.
And for the reverse
direction, it's
k minus 1 times our
intermediate ES.
So now that you remember
how those are done,
you can tell me-- you can
just yell it out-- what
am I going to put for this rate?
K2 times ES.
All right.
So we can always, from
an elementary step
or elementary reaction,
write the rate law just
based on the stoichiometry,
using our rate constants
and our reactants here.
Or for the reverse
direction here.
And then we can write the
overall rate at which product
is being formed.
So the rate of
product formation,
we can write it from the slow
step or from our last step
if we don't know anything
about slow steps.
So the rate at which
product is formed
can be expressed as DPDT, the
change in product over time.
And you can also write it by the
rate law for this second step,
K2 times ES.
But we're not done, because
ES is an intermediate.
It's formed in the
first step, and consumed
in the second step.
And so it's an
intermediate, so we now
have to solve for ES in terms
of rate constants, products,
and reactants.
So how are we going to do this?
And why don't you tell
me how we do this?
And again, this is the
change in ES over time.
So asking for the rate of change
of the intermediate over time.
All right 10 more seconds.
OK.
Yep.
So if you remember back
to the mechanism lecture,
you can solve for ES by
looking at the rate at which ES
is formed, the rate at
which it's decomposed,
and the rate at
which it's consumed.
So the rate of formation
is the forward direction
of the first step minus the
rate at which it decomposes,
which is the back direction
of the first step.
So we have plus K1 E times
S minus k minus 1 times
the intermediate concentration,
and then minus the consumption
minus K2 times ES.
So we put all those
steps together,
and then we need to use the
steady state approximation
to take this to solve for ES.
So again, the steady
state approximation
says that the rate at which
an intermediate forms equals
the rate at which the
intermediate goes away
or the net rate is 0.
So that is again the
steady state approximation,
and they use that in enzyme
kinetics as well as pretty much
every problem you have in
reaction mechanisms-- that's
going to be on the final.
All right so using that
steady state approximation,
we can just take this
expression that we just talked
about and set it
equal to 0, and that
will allow for us to solve
for our intermediate, which
is in this case ES.
So we set that
whole thing into 0.
All right.
So this so far is
exactly the same
as you would do any problem
in reaction mechanisms.
But now, because it's enzymes,
there is a slight difference.
So a slight difference.
And that is that instead
of solving for ES in terms
of E or free enzyme,
we want to solve
for ES in terms of the total
concentration of enzyme, e
to the 0 or O over here.
So total enzyme equals free
enzyme plus bound enzyme
because your enzyme is
either free or bound.
It only has two options, and
so that's your total enzyme.
And the reason why we want
to do this is practical.
We don't necessarily
know if we're
studying its reaction how
much of our enzyme is free
and how much is bound.
But if we're good
scientists, we know
how much enzyme we put
into our experiment.
So total enzyme, if we
can solve for things
and do things in
terms of total enzyme,
that makes our life much easier.
So it's a very practical reason.
So what we can do
now is replace E,
which is our free enzyme,
with our total enzyme
minus our bound enzyme.
So that's what
we're going to do.
I'm going to put back those
expressions we just had.
So this was the
clicker question,
then we set it equal to zero.
And now we have
this E term here.
We want to get rid
of that because we
don't know how much
of our enzyme is free,
but we do know how much
we put in our total.
So we're going to place this E
with total enzyme minus bound
enzyme.
So we have a k1, now instead
of times E we have times E0
times our substrate.
And then we have this ES term,
so minus k1 again, ES times
substrate.
And then you had
these two terms.
We just put those down here.
OK so now we're back.
Now we want to solve
for the intermediate ES,
and we'll solve for
that intermediate ES
in terms now of total enzyme.
All right.
So now we need to do
some rearrangement,
just putting that expression
up here that we just saw.
And now we're going to
rearrange our ES terms.
Everything with an ES to
one side of the equation,
and then solve for it.
So we have all of our
ES terms on one side,
you remove that one, you move
this one, we move that one.
And on the other
side, we just have
this term with k1, total
enzyme and substrate.
Now we can pull out the
ES terms, so ES is here.
We have k1 times
substrate, k minus 1,
k2, and then this
term over here,
k1 total enzyme substrate.
Now we divide, and we
get this term over here.
So now we've solved for ES.
One more change.
There is a constant that's
easy to measure called
the Michaelis-Menten Constant.
And we want to now
introduce this term, big Km,
and this term is equal sub
k minus 1 plus k2 over k1.
Now we want to get this new
constant, Michaelis-Menten
Constant, into this expression
because it's easy to measure.
Again, practical.
So let's do that.
So here's this Km
term again, and we
want this Km term to
appear in this solution
to our intermediate.
We have k minus 1
here, k2, like that,
but there is no
k1 underneath it.
So let's put one there.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to divide by k1.
So we'll divide
the top term by k1.
We'll divide and divide
this k1 S term by k1
and we'll divide k
minus 1 plus k2 by k1,
and we do that because then
we can get our big Km in here.
All right.
So with all of these
dividing by k1s,
we can simplify this expression.
And so we'll do that.
So we'll cancel those k1s.
We can cancel these k1s.
And then we can get this.
Our total enzyme concentration
times substrate over
substrate concentration plus
Km, because that term equals Km.
And now we're happy because
we can measure a Km,
and we know how much
total enzyme we put in.
So we just solved
for our intermediate
in terms of things we
can actually measure.
But we're not done.
This is just the expression
for intermediate.
Now we have to put it
back into our rate law.
So let's do that.
Almost done.
Here is our expression
for our intermediate.
The rate of product
formation, the change
in product over time, equals
K2 times ES, this intermediate.
Now we can plug that in
to that term and do that.
And we get this
expression, which
is known as the
Michaelis-Menten Equation,
k2 times total enzyme
times substrate over
substrate times-- plus Km.
And let me just show you
some pictures of Maude Menten
and Michaelis.
So Michaelis was a professor
in Germany, and he was Jewish.
And he had a bit
of a rocky career,
and was encouraged to do things
that, perhaps, no one cared
about that much, like
study enzymes or something.
And he worked with Maude
Menten, who was Canadian.
So Maude Menten couldn't find
a faculty position in Canada
at the time, so she got
a position in the US
at University of Pittsburgh.
Michaelis decided Germany
was not a good place to be,
and ended up in New York City
at Rockefeller University.
Maude Menten, although she
published an enormous number
of papers, and really
Michaelis-Menten Kinetics
is one of the most
famous things--
if you ask a
biochemist one thing
that everyone will know about
it's Michaelis-Menten kinetics.
She was not promoted
to full professor
until she was 70 years old,
despite the fact that she
had accomplished more
than most anybody else.
And then she retired
at 71 years of age.
So she was a full professor for
one year before she retired.
But Michaelis has had
a rough time, too,
and didn't get his
position that was
worthy of his accomplishments
until he was in his 50s
because of being a German Jew.
So both of them had a
pretty rocky career,
but they were two of the
most prominent figures
really in
biochemistry, setting--
we still use Michaelis-Menten
kinetics all the time
in biochemistry.
So this is really
pioneering work.
OK so let me now
show you how to apply
the Michaelis-Menten equation
to different conditions.
So here we have a plot,
a change in product,
so the rate at which
product is being
formed vs. our
substrate concentration.
So as we-- at low substrate
concentrations down here,
there's a very fast change
in the amount of product
that's being produced per time.
So at low substrate
concentration,
when you add more substrate
it increases the rate
significantly.
And this is because there's
a lot of free enzyme.
So there's enzyme waiting
around to catalyze a reaction.
You give it more substrate,
you get more product quickly.
But this levels off up
here, and at high substrate
concentration,
adding more substrate
doesn't really
help the rate any.
It's leveling off, and that's
because all the active sites
are already filled, so
adding more substrate
doesn't make it any faster.
You need to form
product to release it
for substrate to bind.
And so all the active site are
filled, the rate levels off.
So this is the behavior
that you observe
when typical Michaelis-Menten
kinetics are in play.
So now let's think about
those two conditions again,
or two conditions, one at
high substrate concentration
and one in this range here.
So going back to our equation,
when substrate concentration is
much greater than
Km-- and I'm going
to define Km for you other than
the rate constant in a minute.
So when that is
true, we can look
at the Michaelis-Menten
equation and just
think about what happens if this
substrate concentration is way,
way bigger than Km.
So Km, then is much, much
smaller than substrate,
and it kind of doesn't matter.
So it's very small
and we can ignore it.
And if we cancel out Km, then
we can simplify this equation
even further, and cancel
out our substrates
and we're left with this, that
the rate of product formation
is just k2 times
our total enzyme.
And this has a special name.
This is called Vmax, the
maximum velocity of the enzyme.
So maximum velocity
or maximum rate
equals k2 times your total
enzyme concentration.
So this is one equation that
you'll find on your equation
sheet for the final exam.
And if we go back for a second
and look at our plot up here,
we can now write Vmax,
the maximum velocity
for that particular
enzyme concentration,
k2 times total enzyme.
This is the maximum
rate we're going to get.
So now let's think about this
down here at low substrate
concentrations again, and
particularly at a concentration
where substrate equals Km,
substrate concentration equals
Km.
So if substrate concentration
and Km are the same thing,
we can just put an extra
substrate in there,
Km equals substrate.
So on the bottom we have two
substrate concentrations now,
and that allows us to
cancel out our substrates.
And we're left with this
equation 1/2 k2 times
the total concentration
of enzyme,
which is the half maximal rate.
That's half of Vmax.
Vmax was k2 times total enzyme.
This is half of that, and
this is the definition of Km.
Km is the concentration
of substrate for which
the rate is half maximal.
So if we go back
now to our plot,
this is the maximum rate at
half of that maximal rate.
The substrate
concentration equals Km.
So experimentally,
you can plot your data
for the formation of
product at various substrate
concentrations, calculate
Vmax, and figure out
what was the concentration
of substrate when
the rate was half that maximal
rate, and you can determine Km.
That's why you want
Km in your equation,
because it's something that's
not that hard to measure.
OK.
So let's apply this now.
Let's think about
an enzyme, and we're
told this is enzyme
carbonic anhydrase.
It catalyzed CO2 to
bicarbonate, which
is the buffering system
that happens in your blood,
the Michaelis-Menten
constant for this enzyme,
we have Km 8 times 10
to the minus 5 molar,
and a k2 value of 6 times 5 to
the fifth, I think-- or sixth.
I don't know.
I don't have my
glasses, [? for ?].
Hopefully you can
see better than me.
All right.
So now with these values,
calculate the maximal reaction
rate if the enzyme concentration
is this, which I think
is 5 times 10 to
the something molar.
They should make bigger fonts.
Oh it's easier to read on that.
OK, clicker question.
All right.
10 more seconds.
Yep.
So here you just had to say OK.
If you had your glasses--
and I have my now.
Enzyme concentration
times k2 is going
to give you the maximum rate,
so Vmax equals K2 times enzyme
concentration.
All right.
So we can put that down Vmax
k2 enzyme concentration.
Multiply those out together,
and you get the rate,
and it's in molar per second.
Now what about the concentration
of substrate for the rate
to be 1.5 molar per second?
Another clicker question.
All right.
10 more seconds.
Wow.
OK.
So what is this number compared
to the number we had a before?
It's the half maximal rate.
So what is the enzyme--
the substrate concentration
at the half maximal rate?
Km.
Yeah.
So all you had to do--
that's the definition of Km
is look for the Km
value and say that is
the substrate concentration
when the rate is half maximal.
And so this is the
kind of problem
that you'll have that the
extra problems have in them.
And this can be the
complete answer.
You don't have to show
any work for these.
So a lot of these
problems are just
looking for you to identify
or know what Km means.
So again, that's all
you have to do for this.
So check out the extra
problems on kinetics.
They're not really
extra, they're
on enzymes and things,
reaction mechanisms that
haven't been on a problem set.
They will be on the final exam.
OK and then we'll talk briefly
about inhibitors, clicker
competition Wednesday,
and we're going
to review a lot of
the topics that we've
covered on Wednesday.
So it's going to
be a lot of fun.
And our last video.
All right.
So quickly, we've got to get
to our clicker competition.
So let's finish
lecture 34 notes.
So the last thing we've
been talking about
is one of the most exciting
things in chemistry, which
is catalysis, how do
you speed up reactions?
But we have to end
on a slow note, which
is that inhibitors are
the opposite of catalysts,
and they slow down reactions.
And if we're talking
about enzymes,
which we were doing on Monday,
then inhibitors will often
bind to the enzyme E,
forming an EI complex,
an enzyme inhibitor complex.
And they often bind
in the active site,
and so therefore substrate,
which we have here,
little substrate S, cannot bind.
It's a very simple idea.
If you want to
design an inhibitor
to stop an enzyme from doing
what it's doing-- and in fact
the pharmaceutical industry
is largely about this,
designing inhibitors to bind to
key enzymes to stop processes.
So often what you do
in designing this,
you want something that kind
of looks like a substrate.
But most ideally
you want something
that actually resembles the
transition state-- a transition
state analog.
So you remember catalysts work
by lowering the transition
state or activation energy
barriers, or activated complex.
So they lower that energy.
And so something that resembles
the transition state, where
bonds are partly broken, partly
formed, it's not reactants,
it's not products,
it's in the middle.
Those molecules, those
analogs of transition
states will bond very tightly
and will block the enzyme
from doing its job.
And this is really--
I told you about it--
we had World AIDS
Day I mentioned
that one of the
reasons why AIDS is not
such a huge problem in the
US anymore, it's not a death
sentence anymore, is because
the pharmaceutical industry
designed transition state
analogs targeting HIV protease.
And they really
worked very well.
So for in the developing
world, there's
a good regime of
pharmaceuticals that we can take
that keep the viral load low.
Now it's different in
other parts of the world,
but a lot of the
pharmaceutical industry
is about designing
inhibitors for enzymes.
OK so we've been
talking about catalysis.
We talked about catalytic
mechanisms, catalysts,
we talked about
effect of temperature,
all sorts of things.
And so we're going
to end our catalysis
unit with our final video in
the series In Their Own Words.
And this is a former
graduate student.
She actually just
defended I'm talking
about her work in Tony
Synskey's laboratory,
and why kinetics are
important to our research
and development of biofuels.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name is Jingnan.
I'm from Chongqing China,
and I'm a third year graduate
student working in the chemistry
and biology department.
My research she's on
converting carbon dioxide,
an environmental pollutant,
into a useful biofuel.
Right now, currently, we
burn ethanol in our gasoline.
And ethanol is
not an ideal fuel,
because it's a
shorter chain link,
and the combustion
of heat is not
as high as longer
chain length alcohols.
Also, ethanol traps
a lot of water,
so it can cool off the engine.
When they first found
the Ralstonia eutropha
they realized that this organism
can store a lot of its carbon
as a polymer chain of esters.
And these polyesters,
when isolated,
can be used as
biodegradable plastics.
for my research, I'm trying
to turn this carbon storage
organism into storing the carbon
as biofuels, so an alcohol
that can burn in our engines.
To change these organisms from
making biodegradable plastics
to make biofuels,
first I have to get rid
of the gene that actually makes
the biodegradable plastics,
and then fine tune
another pathway
to shun the excess carbon
into making biofuels.
I really have to
think about kinetics,
because I wanted
my pathway to go
as fast as it can to produce
as much product as possible
within a period of time.
So there are certain parameters
for kinetics that I can change,
and certain parameters
that I cannot change.
For the parameters
that I cannot change,
is the temperature because
my organism would not survive
under higher temperature.
And for parameters that I
can change, for example,
I can change that
enzyme by putting
in a stronger and more efficient
enzyme from another organism
to catalyze the
same exact reaction.
I can also increase the
substrate concentration
by eliminating another competing
pathway for the same substrate
by deleting the gene, so hence
making more of the substrate
out going into my product.
Eventually we'll be able to
take the carbon dioxide that's
released as a
pollutant, and trap it
and use it as a carbon source
to make useful molecules.
[END PLAYBACK]